here is a article from go banking rates
these are in their opinion the five
best
investment apps currently out there 2021
so obviously there's investment apps
galore we can go down a whole laundry
list of what's out there but according
to go banking rates these are the five
best investment apps
right now
okay
so the explosion of investment apps has
opened the stock market to investors of
all capabilities here's a look at the
top five in their opinion so the best
for beginners number one the best for
beginners they got robin hood on i knew
it robin you want to begin you go to
robinhood this is according to them
whereas online brokerage houses have had
a long have long been driving down
commission rates from the hundreds of
dollars even charged by full service
brokers robin hoods was the first to
make commission free trading possible
basically what i'm just saying is
trading commissions used to be out of
control used to be hundreds of dollars
and they brought it down to 25 dollars a
trade that was five dollars a trade yeah
robin hood said zero okay yeah zero free
zero free to trade money but then you
know what they're doing okay you know
what we're making money off of your data
your data we're just selling your data
and your data yeah your data your data
there's no such thing as a free launch
you know how they say that exactly so
how's robinhood making their money
selling your data on the data yeah also
the whole gamestop thing yeah once
people started making money they're like
uh the app crashed well they get a lot
of their funding from some of these
exactly so it's like hedge funds funding
fed funds so so i don't know anyway i
think robin hood long term they're gonna
they're gonna be a player you know short
term with everything that happened with
that they definitely had a black guy
kind of like selling some fake watch or
whatever oh great call back so now
anyway robin hood you can buy stocks
etfs options and crypto for no
commission so that's a big selling point
no commissions there's no count minimums
on robinhood either all right cool so if
you want to get beginning beginner you
want to get started look into robinhood
number two these are your top five
investment apps according to go banking
rates number two
the best
for research tools
is weeble
yes
you ever heard of weeble yeah absolutely
they're always like get to get a free
stock from weeble any any like financial
guy we got a free stock from weeble
maybe we'll look into that
weeble is a contender among the best
investment apps because it has no
account minimums or commissions just
like robin hood right
the app provides real-time quotes a full
financial calendar analyst ratings and
in-depth charts
basically what they're saying is nerds
you've found your place yeah here on
weeble currently we will give you free
stock value between three or three
hundred bucks for simply opening an
account not bad or you can get another
free stock valued at eight to two
thousand dollars eight bucks to two
thousand dollars once you deposit any
amount into your account basically
weeble says give me your money i'll give
you free stock yeah we got the stacks
yeah we got the the research tools
that's number two
weeble number three the best
for additional financial services we'll
expound upon that is a company called
betterment
betterment betterment strength is an
investment app that comes with its from
its variety of features
betterment was created as a robo advisor
so it doesn't allow you to trade stocks
so you're basically they're saying well
manage your money yeah long-term
investing actually truth be told i have
a betterment account i put a couple
thousand it's not my main account by any
stretch of the matter put a couple
thousand bucks i think in an index fund
five years ago it's certainly
appreciated but you know uh not a ton of
money in it because i only put a couple
thousand bucks maybe it's like five
grand at this point
um
basically what happens on betterment is
after you enter your information
and uh with your investment experience
how long you've been investing what you
want to accomplish your objectives your
risk tolerance you know they're going to
basically
decide upon a portfolio that you could
use right and so they're going to use
etfs
that are diversifies your account across
various asset classes it's easy
it's easy to do betterment check it out
number four stockpile this is the best
for educational resources this is
stockpile
basically you ever heard you've heard of
something called fractionalized shares
if you're saying look i can't afford a
thirty five hundred dollar amazon stock
but i'll take a tenth of it right
yeah okay yeah cash bucks cash up helps
you cash app too all right so we'll talk
about cash app stockpile stands out from
the investment app crowd because it
allows for the purchase of
fractionalized shares there it is hit
the nail on the head this can be hugely
important for beginning
investors or for those with a lot with
without a lot of money without a lot of
money to invest because it allows for a
diversified portfolio with even limited
capital they're basically saying look
you can't afford all this stock you
can't afford you know all these
pricier stocks the apples of the world
the amazons of the world the tesla's of
the world the bitcoins well it's not a
stock but yeah but i'm saying like a lot
of these uh investing apps yeah allow
for cryptocurrency and i'm correct sorry
correct no no no maybe getting ahead of
myself but cash app also lets you get
you're there
you're there thank you sir they're
basically saying you can invest in
fractionalized shares a tenth of it less
than a tenth of them right half of it
whatever it is fractionalize a portion
of it so that's number four for best
educational resources stockpile and
number five
something that i'm i'm a fan of but
lukewarm fam and i'll tell you why
uh the best for automated investments is
none other than acorns acorns you've
heard of this app yeah i've seen ashton
kutcher on my youtube ads a couple times
yeah of course ashton good guy
so the acorn caps uh app basically it's
it's a robo advisor okay and it charges
you a couple bucks a month nothing crazy
to allocate your funds among different
etf options we all know that but
basically the trick with acorns is this
is they basically it automatic it rounds
up your spare change so whenever you
make a purchase let's say you're gonna
buy something for
you know nine dollars fifty cents yeah
it takes fifty cents rounds that up boom
now you're investing that 50 cents so it
automatically rounds up that purchase to
the nearest dollar investing in the
additional funds of your portfolio look
there's good and bad with the acorns
because you're only investing 50 cents
yeah okay even if you're you know going
out to a nice dinner and you spend you
know 300 bucks and the bill is
ninety dollars yeah okay so now it's
going to round it up so now you're
investing 10 bucks
not the best way to build your wealth
you know dollar at a time you know you
know typically you want to do more than
that but it's better than nothing
and i interviewed meet kevin one time he
said the reason that he didn't like
acorns is because it associated
investing but spends spending which
makes total sense yeah which investing
is is not spending investing is saving
and then investing so that was his take
on that which i actually agree with good
points with that i don't think he won
for governor of california but the guy
is smart um but these are the top five
investing apps according to go banking
rates with that being said we you know
we're agnostic when it comes to these
investing apps unless
um they want to tell us why we should be
talking about them but these aren't the
only apps there's other apps out there
called wealthfront i've used wealthfront
before you talked about cash apps
they're doing stuff you can buy crypto
on cash app paypal
um i don't know
uh i know that they've invested in
crypto or they accept crypto you got
sofi you got e-trade you got stash you
got personal capital now i invest a lot
of my money with vanguard and i invested
a lot of my money with fidelity to be
frank i actually just go on the website
i don't go on the app
but they have apps too anyway those are
the top investing apps take a look you
know how they say the best way
to build your wealth like the best
thing you can do to build your wealth
the number one indicator
of why you would build wealth you know
some people talk about rate of return
and um that maybe the fees that these uh
apps are charging yeah right you know
aum asset under management fees whatever
whatever you know the best way to make
sure that you have money
putting your money in there yeah
investing your money yeah okay so a lot
of people overthink this kind of stuff
well i don't know it's the fees and the
structure and the diversified portfolio
and i don't know i'm second guessing
shut up nerd
just put your money in there tell them
long term
long term investing yeah obviously fees
are important obviously rate of return
is important but if we don't put your
money in there it's never going to grow
anyway that's that that's my two cents
on that
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken